it's funny people call this movie lame
is every time someone's like Oh lame is
I'm like like lame in some is is French
that's what they're saying they're
saying them is you gotta say lame is Rob
otherwise I gotta assume you're talking
about a wrestler in his underwear and it
just gets confusing to me however let's
review lame is as in the movie not the
guy lame is a Rob lame mr. Rob is a new
movie by Tom Hooper who directed The
King's Speech and it is a musical a
musical based off flame is a Rob which
was a book and then a play and then a
movie and still a play it's been a
hundred different things now in this
iteration it's a movie that is
completely a musical like the Broadway
musical when I say musical I completely
mean musical 99% of the dialogue in this
movie is sung they're these little
connecting phrases where someone will be
like oh they're coming someone will be
like oh they're coming whoa and it'll
start singing those little phrases in
between are the only things that really
are not sung the rest completely done by
note the story involves quite a few
characters but the main character is
Jean Valjean he's played by Hugh Jackman
we first see him at the beginning of the
movie and he's in slavery's one of those
classic tales where it's like yeah he's
in prison but he's a nice guy
they just blows off his parole to be a
criminal and someone gives him an act of
kindness and an act of kindness kind of
I don't know if it messes him up but
he's like why did that happen so he
actually straightens his life out and
becomes a really credible guy however
Russell Crowe's like no no no no you
were a criminal and you blew off your
probation I am coming after you although
he sings it like Russell Crowe sings and
yeah going into this movie you guys know
me by now I like the cool fun movies out
there you know I love the Avengers so I
thought it was gonna be like when I was
a kid my mom was like oh hey let's watch
a movie as a family and I was like okay
call my god it's two VHS tapes long
never fun when you're a kid lame is Rob
is a long movie but it's not actually as
long as you've heard the myth say it is
it's five minutes longer than the Dark
Knight that's how long it is long yeah
the fact that it's a musical drama makes
it seem longer unless you're a fan of
musicals in which case this is your
utopia my friend throughout the course
of the movie there are a lot of other
actors in the movie and Hathaway Amanda
Seyfried Anne Hathaway kicks ass though
she's not in the movie much but when she
is you're like holy musical acting
chops on this check this is one scene
where she hits her lowest low I mean the
movie really is there's a lot of people
who are just not in the best place in
their life right
and she's completely miserable singing
her ass off crying and I was like oh
yeah this is good there's a lot of
emotion behind this about a minute and a
half later I was like how's the camera
cut from her at all I don't know because
I wasn't looking for it but if it didn't
dude good job Anne Hathaway Sacha Baron
Cohen and Helena Bonham Carter in the
movie I don't even think they knew they
were being filmed the entire time
they're there for the comic relief they
sing in the movie but it's almost like
they know that they don't have to sing
well because they're just these wretched
people you're the classic people in the
future scenes of A Christmas Carol who
are all like look what we got here lads
mr. Scrooge's bed sheet yeah people you
don't really want to become when you
grow up and upon everyone in the movie
who sings really well it's really well
acted this is one chick I'd never heard
of her in my life I don't know if I will
but I really hope I do because she's a
good actress and she at least sings well
she should be in more for nothing
else sign her on to Glee for God's sake
from Lamers or optically she would
probably consider her career imploding
at that point I'm just saying man I'm
throwing it out there however there is
Russell Crowe and this is funny when
Moulin Rouge came out in the theaters
and there was the red carpet event at
the Oscars I believe it was the Oscars
that year someone asked Russell Crowe if
he was gonna do musical he was just like
I like to keep the two worlds separate
thinking focus realities next Mesmer it
is and now he's in a musical he probably
should have taken his advice he's not a
great singer he's not as bad as Pierce
Brosnan and Mamma Mia but I am saying if
I have to put earbuds on and listen to
someone sing I'm not gonna be like dude
where the Russell Crowe tracks you
noticed I was doing the iPod with the
wheel do you see that yeah because I
live in the past what I love about this
movie is as dark as it is as low as
people are in their lives in this movie
it's really lutely about hope it's a
movie about how one act of kindness can
change someone's life I gravitated to
that because I like that concept because
I firmly believe it it is called the
miserable but in and among the miserable
people in this movie there is still hope
so lame is Rob as well acted had great
music in it everyone sings well for the
most part it's well shot - you have
these sweeping shots it just puts you in
the time you're like no I'm not looking
at a play or a set I am now transported
into the period thank you awesome
sweeping shot if you're not a fan of
musicals I would say you're not going to
like this movie this movie is not for
everyone it's pretty artsy 99% of the
words are sung in the movie it's I mean
- VHS tapes long man I was there for
Fiddler on the Roof however as someone
who does consider the Opera scene and
final
six a pivotal moment in character
development I enjoyed the hell out of
lame as rob is one of those movies were
if I never see it again I'm not gonna
feel like my life is just incomplete but
in watching it I did enjoy the hell out
of it I will say late miserab is a good
time no alcohol required right so what
is your favorite musical out there I'm
not talking a movie where every word is
sung but you know a movie that takes a
break and there are musical numbers in
it whatever it is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what you
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more